terraform an infrastructure as code tool
that can provision resources in the
cloud
from simple declarative code when
building an app in the cloud you may
find yourself using the graphical user
interface of your favorite cloud
provider
clicking on buttons and paying for
products just like you would on an
e-commerce site the only drawback of
this approach is that it's complete and
total chaos you might click a thousand
different buttons to get your vm
configured properly
but what happens when you need to
reproduce the same thing again in the
future
terraform provides a way to build change
and version infrastructure
safely and efficiently by representing
your infrastructure
and all that settings with the hashicorp
configuration language or optionally
json think of it like a human readable
blueprint that can execute and
automate everything you do in the cloud
it's free and open source
and the first step to get started is to
install the cli on your local system
then from your project create a file
ending in tf
at the top we have a terraform block
that controls global settings for
terraform itself
most importantly we can define providers
here which are like plugins that can
connect to different cloud providers
like aws
google cloud azure etc below that we
have a provider block which gives
terraform the necessary credentials to
connect to our google cloud account
from there we can create actual cloud
infrastructure using a resource block it
takes a type as its first argument which
corresponds to a product on google cloud
then a custom name to identify it as the
second argument
inside the block we can customize the
settings of the resource like its
machine type
zone and anything else you can imagine
now that our infrastructure is defined
as code we can run terraform init to
initialize the project
then terraform apply to make the actual
changes to google cloud
it'll require a confirmation before
making the changes then after it's
complete
the terraform show command can be used
to inspect the current state of the
infrastructure what's awesome
is that as we add more resources to the
configuration terraform keeps track of
the changes or diff
similar to a version control system like
git just run terraform apply again to
deploy any changes to the configuration
now once your startup has failed and it
comes time to tear down the project
use the terraform destroy command as the
inverse of apply to delete everything in
your configuration file this has been
infrastructure as
code with terraform in 100 seconds make
sure to hit the like button if you want
to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one